in the early Saturday I don't know if
you and you know this happened to you
guys
but one of the objections that we get
all the time is you know we have people
who do this or is do the stories we've
got people internally to do this and
it's you know I tell them that there's a
big difference between the way I play
basketball and the way LeBron James
plays back there's no accident that
Ella's the best you've got right you
just tell them right to the [ __ ] face
that we're better at it
yeah and if they say well we don't value
the difference between our B player and
you're a player then you say Mazel Tov
and you go into the next building yeah
don't dwell on that conversation tell
them right in the face what you believe
and move on cool I mean it's that basic
yeah what are you try to convince the
unsellable right I don't give a [ __ ]
what your excuses it's the excuse and
I'm leaving constantly and I was a guy
yes I was a [ __ ] guy and I got it and
I said great I'll see you in 2015 yeah
and so the companies that passed on
paying me $5,000 a month came in four
years later paying me $80,000 a month
they [ __ ] up and I loved it yeah
because they deserve it but I didn't
dwell on it or waste my time building my
business get over it move on and go to
the next person there's unlimited people
you can actually get to yeah we can
rethink that next but you need to really
nail that one in your brain it will be
the best thing that happens to your
business sitting in your bed crying
about the girl that didn't want to go
out with you for a year is not going to
let you find the next girl
yeah I agree next agree so in that one
of the things that we're doing as an
agency you know I think similar to you
guys is you know we have things that we
want to do on the side we were thinking
about it and complicating information is
letter that we're doing get big enough
that the distractions are worthwhile
yeah but don't kill the mothership so
that that was kind of a question right
because I've been part of three other
startups in my own previous career and
any successful one wall comedy
acquire are you whenever sitting at the
top no God I'm a part of the drivers
respect by always but always like that
day one or equally so you got to see a
lot i yeah a little 300 yep good create
my own video about that but how do you
have anything i used to call this when
when those honors would go off onto
those things that are called the court
were distractions yes me now i want to
do it online these other things when
you're not tripping or you have a
wavering i yep you're unfaithful that
skirt looks cute I get it I've never you
know it's when it comes to
entrepreneurship I'm playing the field
hard I'm super in love with Vayner but
I'm like lose that and that happens to
me every day I'm a scum bucket when it
comes to entrepreneurship and I would
tell you that you can go and have a
little more fun once you've got a little
bit of an established situation so I
would say that be very careful of not
doing it too early and realize you know
there's something I've said the other
day like eat [ __ ] for 24 months and then
caviar the rest of your life it's not
that exact but that's how I think about
here build something that gives you the
[ __ ] you know build something and then
when it's got enough strikes go do it
the reason there was a big gap in me
putting out content was I needed two
thousand eleven twelve and thirteen to
build Vayner it allowed me them to get
back into content do the pure well deal
you know yeah I used to watch my own
revision three so I used to run video
and good magazine and good back in the
gym you know in early you today's are so
amazing just the video was good and the
content was doing those audience for it
you know hundreds of thousands in super
handy
so we sit there and watch you know
revision free right tekzilla and yep in
Avondale who is this guy talking about
will hunting in New Jersey was it was an
amazing
it seems so insane right it was like
everything was packed right so it was
just like that's exactly you said it
perfectly
meter is a wine and jet what's up guys
for 20 minutes
anything thank you and you know finally
you know I just really wanted to thank
you I said in my house you know I kind
of stirred health issues that's how all
the fiat born and this is so I got well
through this like total food situation
and while that was all happening with
tremendous resulting period around the
time you're doing Jab Jab Jab right hook
and so like response also thank you
because with all the energy that you
were pouring out on those videos was
just like my inspiration every data keep
doing what I was doing and you know and
I was literally like left hand by like
mainstream doctors and work like fluke
encounter with someone who lets these
amazing guys specializes in Crohn's and
Colitis as well as the pediatric
mitochondrial disorders that got me on
so it's really unique wealth path of
wellness that took like a year so like I
would sit on my treadmill as part of my
TV and watch these Gary DVD all day long
so I just wanted it all this for super
it's super hard to consume that because
it just means so much to me I am I don't
have to say but thank you so much like
her thanks thank you I am its would live
in such an amazing time like if I was
born 30 40 years earlier I just would
have been a really well liked successful
businessman in some neighborhood right
we're just so lucky to be living in this
time more like listen man I don't know
how what it's going to feel like when I
buy the Jets but I'm really going to
struggle cuz they could feels any better
than the way my heart feels right now I
really mean it
yes another seeming you know like think
about that and I feel like I'm just
getting started so like pretty cool
thank you very much without thank you so
much laughing yeah on the sizing that
we're working on if we get a little more
bass would it be okay if out 100 more
5-month you made me feel really good
right now you've got yourself some
letters yes yes that would be very cool
yeah of course thank you yeah of course
awesome
thank you so much every time appreciate
it they very kind I really don't have to
thank me work out for you maybe yeah and
one yes you're happier than I on that
gratitude brother drive with that do not
let any like when I gave you that first
answer to that question now that should
be a foregone conclusions yeah
comparatively to never you know is what
happens with life-threatening events you
forget it's like it's like getting it's
like when the cop car goes and then when
it drives back by you you get I mean you
start driving fast again people don't
realize if you do I understand is that
God I've never had it people forget do
not forget music but but but you know
what
don't say it live it right losing that
client somebody saying no nothing real
pleasure yes thank you still yeah okay
so but